und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka gegen
abend es ist ja nun mal so in einer
demokratie besteht politik vor allem
darin mehrheiten zu organisieren
schafft man das nicht setzt man auch
nichts durch noch nicht mal teile dessen
was einem wichtig ist
insofern könnten die berliner
großkoalitionären eigentlich zufrieden
in die woche starten
sie haben einen kompromiss gefunden für
die einführung einer grundrente die für
mehr gerechtigkeit sorgen soll
wer jahrzehntelang rentenbeiträge
geleistet hat soll im alter besser
gestellt seien als sozialhilfeempfänger
und wie es in der natur von kompromissen
liegt beide seiten haben dabei etwas
durchgesetzt und beide seiten haben
abstriche machen müssen
das problem liegt darin dass es in
dieser großen koalition inzwischen viele
gibt die nur noch die löcher sehen und
nicht dem käse butter spiekermann
berichtet der tag nach dem kompromiss
zur grundrente ist bei der spd ein
entspannter ist wird gelächelt es wird
getätschelt man ist zufrieden mit sich
selbst von einem sieg im grund
rentenstreit ist zwar nicht die rede
hubertus heil bemüht lieber das große
ganze es ist wichtig wenn man die
demokratie fortschritte erzielen will
dass man auch zu guten kompromissen in
der lage ist sonst gibt es keinen
fortschritt der demokratie am seidenen
faden hing die groko die letzten wochen
und monate nun gibt man vor an einem
gemeinsamen strang zu ziehen
doch die kritiker vor allem in der cdu
wollen nicht verstummen die jüngeren
regieren auf es gebe jetzt aber
wichtigeres lässt die parteivorsitzende
durchblicken
es geht nicht darum den altona anderen
flügel zu befriedigen zuerst einmal geht
es darum eine sachgerechte lösung zu
finden für die bürgerinnen und bürger
die davon betroffen sind und die jetzt
profitieren das sind durchaus eine ganze
reihe von menschen drei gegenstimmen
heute im bundesvorstand sie kommen aus
der jungen union und vom
wirtschaftsflügel
sie sehen sich als kompromiss verlierer
die kritik es werde darauf verzichtet
die wirkliche bedürftigkeit bei der
grundrente zu überprüfen es wiegt schwer
dass wir auf die bedürftigkeitsprüfung
verzichten natürlich müssen diejenigen
die lange arbeiten mehr haben
als diejenigen die nicht oder wenig
arbeiten aber es bedarf eine
bedürftigkeitsprüfung dass wir prüfen
hat jemand vermögen ja oder nein das ist
deutsche sozialpolitik und daran müssen
wir festhalten
die grundrente soll es nach 35 jahren
arbeit und beitragszahlung geben
das einkommen soll von den finanzämtern
überprüft werden nicht das gesamte
vermögen wie von der union gefordert 1,2
bis 1,5 millionen geringverdiener
könnten profitieren
die kosten belaufen sich auf bis zu 1,5
milliarden euro im jahr
die kritik der opposition ist umfassend
aus unserer sicht sollte die grundrente
schon nach 30 beitragsjahren nicht erst
nach 35 beitragsjahren greifen aber
zentral ist dass die grundrente kommt
weil die menschen haben schon viel zu
lange darauf gewartet dass die
bundesregierung endlich was gegen
altersarmut die gestrige einigung ist
eine vertane chance
die sozialpolitik neu auszurichten ganz
offensichtlich war den verhandelnden der
schutz der groko wichtiger als der
schutz vor altersarmut die große
koalition hat sich mit einem schlechten
kuhhandel mit einem in der sache
schlechten kompromiss der einerseits
ungerecht ist und zum anderen unseriös
finanziert zeit gekauft tatsächlich
wackelt die finanzierung für die
grundrente soll die
finanztransaktionssteuer aus
börsengeschäften herangezogen werden
diese steuer gibt es aber noch gar nicht
die groko hat aber möglicherweise zeit
gewonnen wichtige parteitage für cdu und
spd stehen bevor
der grund rentenkompromiss könnte die
koalition retten vorläufig über die
militärischen erfolge beim kampf gegen
die terror milizen des islamischen
staates hat man sich auch in europa und
den usa gefreut
dazu gehört dass auf den syrischen und
iranischen schlachtfeldern auch
zahlreiche ausländische kämpfer gefangen
genommen wurden das problem ist nur
niemand will sie haben beziehungsweise
niemand will sie zurück haben
das problem hatten schon die kurden das
problem haben auch die türken die teile
dieser lager im norden syriens
übernommen haben aber auch in der türkei
selbst sitzen maß licher es leute in
gefängnissen
manche waren dort auf der durchreise als
sie festgenommen
ankara will sie loswerden mann sei kein
zitat hotel für ausländische extremisten
heute soll der erste häftling nach
deutschland abgeschoben werden unklar
allerdings ob es sicher behauptung eines
kämpfe handelt das wort berichtet wie
gut eine regierung auf unliebsame
überraschungen vorbereitet ist zeigt
sich auch daran wer etwas weiß und wann
wer es dem anderen sagt das
innenministerium ist das
sicherheitsministerium gefahrenabwehr
terrorismusbekämpfung all das und dann
das wir wissen dass die türkei personen
nach deutschland abschieben will mir ist
zumindest als ich eben das ministerium
verlassen habe nicht bekannt ob die
konkreten personalien schon vorliegen
das ist aber eine wichtige information
um gezielt einschätzung vornehmen zu
können die beiden gruppen die ich heute
morgen genannt haben wurden uns heute
morgen von der türkischen seite auch die
personalien genannt
und die haben sie aber noch nicht als
bmw leute gegeben wurde wie ich gehe
davon aus dass es wahrscheinlich in der
letzten stunde oder so passiert ist
drei männer fünf frauen zwei kinder zum
teil vielleicht aus einem dieser lage im
norden syriens wo kurdische kämpfer den
diaz besiegt hatten die sich seit den
türkischen einmarsch aber in auflösung
befinden
womöglich aber darunter auch eine
siebenköpfige familie die nie in syrien
war
selbst stunden später am früheren abend
in paris liefert der außenminister vor
allem fragen wollen wissen wer da zu uns
kommt wissen dass es sich bei den fällen
oder die im moment gesprochen wird im
wesentlichen um frauen kinder handelt
also um familien aber darüber hinaus
wollen wir überprüfen ob es personen
gibt die in irgendeiner weise mit dem
esm verbindung zu bringen sind
diplomatisch ist dass eine frau die
türkei schiebt deutsche abspricht von
aes kämpfern liefert dafür bislang aber
offenbar keine beweise
ankara setzt berlin massiv unter druck
deshalb erwarte ich auch von
bundesaußenminister damit seinen guten
kontakten die türkei dafür sorgt dass
wir nicht überrumpelt werden
ich würde nicht erpressung nennen aber
überrumpelt ist es schon sollten
zahlreiche es kämpfe in kurzer zeit nach
deutschland zurückkehren während die
sicherheitsbehörden womöglich bald
überfordert
wir sind da sehr wach aber es ist
natürlich in einem freien land auch ganz
schwierig alle vorbereitungshandlungen
frühzeitig zu erkennen das ist uns bis
jetzt meistens aber gelungen das problem
ist hausgemacht zu lange habe die
regierung auf zeit gespielt sich vor
lösungsversuchen gedrückt so sieht es
die opposition ja dieses auf zeit
spielen war falsch wir hätten die chance
gehabt rechtzeitig sie zurückzuholen das
hat die bundesregierung verpasst und nun
sind wir in einer ganz schwierigen
situation die wir dann noch bewältigen
müssen was die bundesregierung aber
dringend tun sollte ist diese rückkehr
geordnet zu regeln also nicht darauf zu
warten dass die leute sich sozusagen
selbst auf den weg machen und dann
möglicherweise unter dem radar der
sicherheitsbehörden bleiben gut möglich
dass es dafür nun zu spät ist
erdogan kann den preis für seine
kooperation nach oben treiben besonders
schwer macht ihm die bundesregierung das
nicht
zudem gefährde an die der
verfassungsschutz hierzulande ist schon
im auge hat oder haben sollte könnten
also auch noch rückkehrer kommen die
bereits radikalisiert waren und jetzt
auch noch eigenes kriegs erleben hinter
sich haben dass das bekehren und wirkt
sollte man besser nicht hoffen was führt
menschen überhaupt dazu freiwillig in
einen terror krieg zu ziehen
überhaupt zu solcher gewalt bereit zu
sein so zu hassen dass man sogar fähig
ist für eine religion oder eine
ideologie oder ein rassistisches
weltbild zu töten
woher kommt hast die kernfrage der
extremismus forschung starregisseur
steven spielberg hat dazu eine
sechsteilige dokureihe produziert die
das zdf in dieser woche ausstrahlt aus
hätte daraus hat benjamin salewski
zusammen gestimmt frank wächst auf in
philadelphia
dort lernt er zu hassen mein stiefvater
kam zu uns als ich neun war erlebte dort
vier jahre mit ihm kam die gewalt es
begannen gleich in der ersten woche ein
tyrann lebte in unserem haus ich hasste
ihn er war der erste mensch den ich
hasste es beginnt oft mit einem traum
aber jedem einzelnen der sich
radikalisiert sowie bei frank
identitätskrise und weiß nicht wo man
hingehört
wir sehen extremistische gruppen oft als
manifestation von gewalt war
was sie bieten ist ein gefühl von liebe
unterstützung familie zugehörigkeit
das alles findet frank in der nazi
gemeinschaft er wird skinhead
gewalttätig kommt ins gefängnis wie
radikalisieren sich menschen das zeigt
die doku auch anhand des dschihadisten
jesse der zu mohammed wird die neue
salafistische idee machte ich habe sie
auf gesunken
der weg zum extremismus gleicht sich der
extreme rechte und der islamistische
teil des spektrums erzählen die gleiche
geschichte mein weg ist der einzig
richtige und mit dem rest passen wir
nicht zusammen dieses denken führt auf
mainstream
das hätten wir uns nicht vorstellen
können das passiert auch weil dieses
denken von ganz oben genährt wird
wir müssen zurückschlagen
und wer jetzt denkt alles sei nur
schrecklich der bekommt etwas hoffnung
frank arbeitet nach dem gefängnis bei
einem juden lernt den menschen kennen
überwindet vorurteile
ich hoffe wenn menschen die serie sehen
dass die erkenntnis sein wird
redet miteinander redet über das was wir
gemeinsam haben denkt nicht was uns
trennt
ich glaube wir sind mitten in einem
sturm der frieden und die soziale
harmonie die wir im westen so lange und
gerne gelebt haben sind plötzlich
zerbrechlich das ist eine aufgabe für
jede gruppe der gesellschaft uns alle
ich glaube daran dass wir eine wende
schaffen können aber wir müssen es tun
die ganze folge zum thema extremismus
können sie im zdf morgen abend sehen um
20 15
diese doku reihe warum wir hassen
umfasst aber viele facetten dann geht es
nicht nur um politischen extremismus
sondern auch im haus im alltag fünf
folgen sind bereits jetzt in unserer
mediathek abrufbar die sechste und
letzte folge wird am 18 november online
gestellt und mit den protesten in
hongkong geht es jetzt hier
nachrichtenbeitrag bei diesen protesten
gab es ein weiteres mal schwere
auseinandersetzungen
ein polizist schoss während eines
handgemenges auf einen demonstranten und
traf ihn in den oberkörper glaubt
behörden wurde der demonstrant operiert
sein zustand sei stabil
die polizei setzte auch tränengas ein
radikale demonstranten warfen steine und
brandsätze
ein mann wurde offenbar nach einem
streit mit einer flüssigkeit übergossen
und angezündet
regierungschefin lemm erklärte die
regierung werde sich dem druck nicht
beugen
die gewalt gehe inzwischen weit über die
forderungen nach demokratie hinaus nach
der bereits zweiten parlamentswahl in
spanien in diesem jahr bleibt es bei dem
politischen patt die wähler gaben
gestern weder den sozialdemokraten noch
den konservativen eine klare mehrheit
die sozialdemokraten von
ministerpräsident sein schuss holte mit
28 prozent die meisten stimmen auf den
zweiten platz kamen die konservativen
mit knapp 21 prozent massiv zulegen
konnten die rechtspopulisten sie sind
jetzt drittstärkste kraft
die beiden großen parteien hatten eine
koalition bislang ausgeschlossen
feiertag heute in polen am 11 november
wird daran erinnert dass polen 1918 die
unabhängigkeit wiedererlangt hat diesen
tag nutzten auch wieder nationalistische
und radikale gruppen in warschau nahmen
zehntausende teil
die veranstaltung richtete sich unter
anderem gegen migranten abtreibung und
homosexualität
es gab auch gegendemonstrationen das
bundeskriminalamt verzeichnet mehr
straftaten im bereich der
cyberkriminalität nach einem neuen
bericht stieg die zahl der fälle auf
mehr als 87.000 dazu gehören hacker
angriffe auf unternehmen datendiebstahl
das ausspähen persönlicher daten
aber auch die verbreitung von
schadsoftware als grund für den anstieg
nannte das bka die zunehmende
verbreitung digitaler geräte der
kindesmissbrauchs fall von bergisch
gladbach weitet sich aus die polizei
hatte einen achten verdächtigen im
nordrhein-westfälischen lünen
festgenommen die fälle waren
bekanntgeworden nachdem bei einer
durchsuchung ende oktober eine große
datenmenge mit fotos und videos von
sexueller gewalt an kindern gefunden
wurde
die auswertung dauert noch an das ganze
ausmaß der taten ist noch unklar
in australien wüten weiter schwere
buschbrände
wegen der massiven bedrohung hat der
bundesstaat new south wales den notstand
ausgerufen und auch für sinn der und
umgebung gilt die höchste feuer waren
stufen über 1.000 feuerwehrleute kämpfen
gegen die flammen
mehr ist die hälfte der brände ist außer
kontrolle
bisher kamen mindestens drei menschen
ums leben man kann ganze politik bücher
füllen mit den geschichten von
erfolgreichen revolutionieren die als
hoffnungsträger an die macht kamen und
dann nicht mehr von ihr lassen konnten
und auch kein widerspruch mehr zuließen
obwohl sie einst doch selbst unter
politischer unterdrückung gelitten
hatten
aus einer diktatur eine freiheitliche
demokratie zu formen ist jedenfalls eine
aufgabe an der schon viele gescheitert
sind
in diese riege reiht sich auch boliviens
evo morales ein
nun würde er vom militär zum rücktritt
gezwungen auch das ist ja ein typischer
verlauf der nichts gutes verheißt für
das weitere schicksal boliviens dass er
vorab berichtet am morgen danach
herrscht eine zerbrechliche ruhe auf den
straßen von la paz die trümmer der
ausschreitungen der nacht rauch noch
kurzes durchatmen
zeit für ein paar gedanken zum sturz von
präsident morales
er hat viele fehler gemacht er hat doch
viel gutes getan
aber am ende hat er es einfach
übertrieben am ende hat jeder gespürt
dass präsident morales seine macht
missbraucht er hat nicht mehr auf uns
gehört hatte kein gespür mehr für das
was die menschen wirklich wollen
nach wochen des protestes hat die
ankündigung des rücktritts von evo
morales in weiten teilen boliviens für
jubel gesorgt nachdem die organisation
der amerikanischen staaten erhebliche
manipulationen bei seiner wahl
festgestellt hatte kündigt der zunächst
neuwahlen an
wird dann aber von der armee
unmissverständlich aufgefordert
zurückzutreten was er kurz darauf tot
wobei ja die opposition mit den
ungewöhnlichen worten angreift einen
putsch der bürger angezettelt zu haben
bestimmte kräfte haben immer mehr gewalt
und aggression gestört und aus diesem
und vielen anderen gründen trete ich
hiermit zurück den vorwurf des putsches
was die opposition kategorisch zurück
die ereignisse der letzten tage zeigen
wie das bolivianische volk heldenhaft
und friedlich dem kontinent und der welt
eine lektion in sachen demokratie
erteilt hat es ist die chronik eines
angekündigten abstürze wie so oft in
südamerika vom helden des volkes zum
verhassten despoten evo morales war der
erste indigene präsident lateinamerikas
ursprünglich ein bauer ein echter mann
des volkes der diese karte lange zeit
gut zu spielen weiß mit seiner
sozialistischen umverteilungspolitik
halbiert er fasst die armut verdoppelt
das pro kopf einkommen
doch später regiert er zunehmend
autoritär betreibt vetternwirtschaft
verfolgt andersdenkende mit seiner
vierten kandidatur bricht er die
verfassung ignoriert ein referendum
dagegen und lässt anscheinend das
ergebnis fälschen
das volk steht als erstes auf am ende
schließen sich auch militär und polizei
an
wir können uns nicht gegen das volk
stellen die regierung benutzt uns zur
unterdrückung des volkes aber wir sind
den menschen verpflichtet putsch oder
volksaufstand je nach ideologischer
heimat fällt das urteil im in und
ausland in die eine oder andere richtung
aus und vergisst dabei wie so oft bei
südamerika jegliche zwischentöne
und vor allem die frage um die es
wirklich geht wie weiter mit bolivien
denn die unruhen sind noch nicht vorbei
es brennt aber nicht nur in bolivien in
einer ganzen reihe südamerikanischer
länder gibt es derzeit ja schwere
politische unruhen in venezuela schon
seit langem
aber auch in anderen ländern des
kontinents sind lang schwelende
konflikte in letzter zeit offen
ausgebrochen
so gibt es massenproteste aktuell auch
in chile und ecuador
dabei wird unseren südamerika
korrespondenten christoph röcke rat
sprechen christoph die bilder ähneln
sich aber die ausgangslagen in diesen
ländern sind ja sehr unterschiedlich
also mit einfachen politischen rechts
links schema tag und da eigentlich nicht
weiter
damit kommt man tatsächlich nicht weiter
wir erleben es ja gerade in chile
demonstrieren die menschen gegen eine
rechte regierung der mann eine
neoliberale ungerechte politik vorwirft
und über libyen wurde eben gerade ein
linker präsident abgesetzt den mann
vetternwirtschaft und korruption vor
wirft beiden gemein ist dass sie nicht
geschafft haben die kluft zwischen arm
und reich den südamerika halt ganz
besonders groß ist zu überwinden so dass
sich nach wie vor viele menschen
abgehängt fühlen uns der politik einfach
nicht mehr vertrauen wenn sie
irgendetwas verspricht wir haben das
zeigen untersuchungen gerade in
südamerika ein großes misstrauen
gegenüber der demokratie laut neuesten
umfragen glauben weniger als die hälfte
der südamerikaner daran dass die
demokratie die beste regierungsform ist
und das ganze hat natürlich auch eine
geschichte das sind alles länder die mal
kolonialherr herrschaften hatten die
auch die meisten hatten auch
militärdiktaturen bis vor nicht allzu
langer zeit so dass politik in
südamerika meistens auch mit gewalt
verbunden war das trägt natürlich die
menschen alles hat hier noch nicht die
zeit gegeben für viele auch für die
politik sozusagen durchlässiger zu
werden also die menschen mehr zu
integrieren einen echten glauben in eine
politik die von unten kommen zu
etablieren so dass viele immer wieder
dann auch bei populisten zum teil an die
etwas versprechen und das daneben dann
nicht halten können wie wir immer wieder
sehen und all diese länder haben ja
außerdem noch eines gemeinsam nämlich
große rohstoffvorkommen welche rolle
spielt das der rohstoff boom hat dafür
gesorgt dass viele regierungen egal ob
links oder rechts ohne wirklich viel
selbst dafür tun zu müssen
auf einmal sehr große gewinne einfahren
konnten es sind objektiv die zahl der
mittelschicht ist objektiv gestiegen vor
allem konnte man die eigene klientel
versorgen aber die regierung habe neben
versäumt das ganze für groß angelegte
reformen zu nutzen
das heißt ich kann jetzt vielleicht als
mit als neuer mittelschichtler mehr
konsumieren in meinem land aber die
schulen sind noch genauso schlecht die
krankenhäuser sind genauso schlecht der
busse überfüllt die infrastruktur
funktioniert nicht und das führt eben
dazu dass diese scheinbar gefühl der
sicherheit ich habe auf einmal geld dann
wieder enttäuscht wird durch die geringe
oder nicht besser gewordene soziale
sicherheit also wieder ein großes gefühl
der enttäuschung ein misstrauen ist die
politik ist nicht geschafft hat die
menschen hier mitzunehmen und das führt
eben dann zu solchen enttäuschungen und
eben solchen großen frust reaktionen die
wir in allen ländern immer wieder sehen
dankeschön für diese analysen christoph
volkert
danke und jetzt gibt's noch mal andere
meldung des tages von hans wolf die
bundesregierung hat in ihrem vor kurzem
beschlossenen eckpunkten für eine
mobilfunk strategie das ziel ausgegeben
den netzausbau in deutschland jetzt
schnell voranzubringen
am kommenden wochenende gibt es dazu
eine digital klausur der regierung
heute gab es frank bild man bereits eine
ankündigung großer mobilfunkbetreiber
für den hausbau genau die großen drei
die deutsche telekom vodafone und
telefonica deutschland wollen künftig
ihre kräfte bündeln von einer allianz
gegen funklöcher oder weiße flecken ist
da die rede
zu diesem zweck wurde heute eine
absichtserklärung unterzeichnet die
unternehmen beabsichtigen darin 6000
neue mobilfunkstandorte aufbauen und
gemeinsam nutzen zu wollen
insbesondere auf dem land entlang von
verkehrswegen wie straßen schienen und
flüssen sollen diese entstehen
das war die auflage unter der die
konzerne im sommer für insgesamt 6,5
milliarden euro die frequenzen für den
superschnellen mobilfunk standard 5g
erwerben konnten
schon damals regte sich in anbetracht
der milliardensumme unmut die
mobilfunkbetreiber kritisierte nun
stehen nicht mehr genügend geld für den
ausbau der netze zur verfügung und
überhaupt ob es statthaft sei die lizenz
nur unter solchen auflagen zu
versteigern sollen die gerichte klären
trotz der heutigen angekündigten allianz
heißt es in einer pressemitteilung des
wegen die drei unternehmen halten die
auflagen nach wie vor
für unverhältnismäßig und rechtswidrig
weshalb sie ihre laufenden klagen
aufrechterhalten
unabhängig davon durch die bündelung der
kräfte darf nun auf besseres
telefonieren und surfen entlang von
autobahnen und in zügen gehofft werden
ab wann dazu wollen sich die konzerne
allerdings erst im kommenden frühjahr
äußern
frank bethmann vielen dank für die
deutschen leichtathleten bei der para wm
in dubai gab es heute zwei weitere
medaillen über die 100 meter gewann
johannes flores gold und felix streng
holte bronze er ist der klare favorit
johannes flores spätestens nach seinem
weltrekord im vorlauf 2 behandeln neben
ihm sein teamkollege felix strengen der
einzige der in diesem jahr auch schon
unter elf sekunden gelaufen ist
flores auf band vier streng auf 6 und
auf 7 das mit afrikanern longo zunächst
sind die drei in etwa gleich augen doch
dann rauscht johannes voss davon in
10,60 sekunden ist ein vier zehntel
schneller als der zweitplatzierte
wer mit dem zielfoto gefunden werden
muss silber getauchten an den
südafrikaner bronze damit für felix
strengen der sich mit den neuen
weltmeister johannes voß über zwei
weitere deutsche medaillen freuen kann
elfter elfter elfter elfter elf uhr elf
dann war es wieder soweit närrischer
frohsinn in den karneval
in mainz auch in köln starteten tausende
jecken in die neue session
die dauert waren ist 26 februar also
netto und zum schluss noch ein blick in
die zukunft der deutsche lehrerverband
feiert heute sein 50 jähriges bestehen
und blickt sinnvollerweise weniger
zurück als nach vorn
wie sieht die schule der zukunft aus was
sollte sich ändern
darüber kann man sich natürlich
trefflich streiten gerade im bereich der
schulbildung gibt es ja auch immer
wieder neue konzepte kaum eine
generation an der nicht diese oder jene
bildungsreform ausprobiert wird mit mehr
oder weniger erfolg
klar ist aber auch schule wie vor 100
jahren würde heute nirgendwo mehr
funktionieren und auch die schule von
heute wird sich künftig wandeln
welche ideen ist da schon gibt zeigt
sein rücken
jeden morgen setzt sich caroline wird
guide ihre schaffner mütze auf und
vergibt platz tickets die sind am weiter
für gymnasium sehr begehrt die schule im
hamburger norden nutzt auch ihre flure
kreativ als sogenannte lernkompetenz für
die man eben tickets braucht die ideen
die flure auf diese weise mit fürs
lernen zu rufen soll dazu führen dass
die schüler nicht so kaserniert sind
nicht nur in räume gehen die
vordefiniert sind sondern sich diesen
nischen und ecken suchen
je nachdem was gerade zu ihrer aufgabe
passt jeden tag eine stunde studienzeit
arbeiten alleine oder im team auf den
fluren oder in den klassenzimmern
schüler lernen nach und nach sich und
ihre zeit einzuteilen arbeiten fast wie
an der uni zürich in den ersten jahren
sie das selbstständige lernen aber man
wird halt auch gut daran herangeführt
und man lernt eben nicht nur sich die
zeit selbst einzuteilen sehr gut sondern
eben auch schwerpunkte zu setzen ich
meine mal sitzt den ganzen tag so einem
klassenraum und dann braucht man halt
irgendwie so ein bisschen abwechslung
dass sie den fluren und das gymnasium
hat zudem einen ableger im internet mit
virtuellen lernräume auf die schüler und
lehrer von überall zugriff haben
flexibles lernen ein mögliches
erfolgsmodell für die zukunft wenn
schule denn darf all das muss an einer
schule erprobt werden dafür brauchen die
kollegen zeit und dafür brauche es mut
und mein eindruck ist dass es gerade
wenn ich diesen rückschritt mir angucke
fokussierung auf die kernfächer
fokussierung auf lehrpläne die bildung
definieren das ist nicht mutig ein
rückgriff auf das bildungsfernsehen
vergangener zeiten dagegen kann mutig
sein online star daniel jung holte sich
heute mit seiner matte youtube schule
beim fünfzigsten geburtstag des
lehrerverbandes gute noten ab das
bereitstellen durch digitale
unterstützung in kombination jetzt mit
dem lehrer der zukunft der affinen auch
dazu ist zu solchen technologien wird
glaube ich so dieses diesen heiligen
gral der individualisierung nach vorne
treiben dass man wirklich selbst in
mathematik zum spaß kommt also dann auch
zum erfolg auch die schule von türen
lengwenus zeigt wie bildungs zukunft
heute aussieht
oder und schulleiter entwickeln
gemeinsam ihre schule im rahmen der
bildungspläne aber mit eigenen
schwerpunkten bei 84 nationen unter
einem dach spielt integration dabei eine
große rolle
dann die andere den weg lasst ihr könnt
euch dann können wir voneinander und
zwei landet werden
man muss ein bisschen vertrauen in
schulen stecken
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten geben dann
können auch kleine gedanken die schüler
haben oder eltern oder alle an schule
beteiligten dank an die wachsen und groß
werden und das projekt rassismus freie
schule ist so eine gewachsene idee die
initiative dazu kommt von schülern die
gerade mal in einer sechsten klasse sind
von uns im heute-journal gleich nach dem
wetter geht es im montagskino weiter und
danach um 0 uhr meldet sich an der
zimmermann mit heute plus ist morgen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter unser planet
erwärmt sich immer weiter und da sieht
man ganz besonders gut auf den monat
zurückblicken und der oktober 2009 10
war sogar der wärmste bisher schaut man
auf europa sieht man über weiten teilen
auch es war zu warm auch nach russland
in nur großbritannien und skandinavien
war zu kalt und schauen sie richtung
arktis da war es viel zu warm
das ist der bereich des planeten der
sich am schnellsten oder am stärksten
erwärmt vom klima rückblick auf die
vorausschau das ist der film für die
nächsten 24 stunden und sie sehen hier
ein tief wird sich richtung nordsee
bewegen und neue wolke mitbringt und
auch regen dabei dreht der wind auf
südwest
schauen wir uns das ganze ein bisschen
genauer an in der nacht schneit es im
süden bis auf 500 meter herab im
nordwesten kommen neue wolken und der
wind kräftig aus südwest schon mal an
der nordsee temperaturen dazu gehen
zurück bis auf minus 1 grad im vogtland
und 5 grad zum beispiel an der ems
momentan ist von auf bilden sich schauer
im westen da kann es auch auf 500 meter
herab etwas schneiden das auch nach
osten und süden hin
ja und an den alpen da kommt ebenfalls
schnee dazu nach norden und da zeigt
sich auch mal die sonne die temperaturen
erreichen maximal werte von 2 grad an
den alpen und neuen graz nach ost nennen
die nächsten tage am mittwoch in der
südhälfte viele wollten noch mal nass
mit regen und schnee bei ein bis sieben
grad und am donnerstag da wird es schon
wieder trockener bei 2 bis 8 grad
ein schöner abend